artificial intelligence researchers that
deepmind have mastered pong chess and go
but some games are on another level the
game of Starcraft 2 one of the most
complicated video games ever created it
is a real-time strategy game which means
that you don't take turns you play and
you have to play fast it was clear that
Starcraft would be a great grand
challenge for us to tackle using an
artificial intelligence the techniques
we love namely neural networks deep
reinforcement learning and so on so
forth my name is Oreo videos and I'm the
lead researcher of the Alpha Star
project alpha star is an artificial
intelligence system that plays the game
Starcraft 2 so the first element of
StarCraft that's quite different is that
you don't get to see what's happening on
the other side of the board that it's
what we call imperfect information and
is a key challenge that neither in chess
or NGO are present another key
difference is that the pieces of chess
or what we call units in StarCraft are
created throughout the game right so you
start with very very few units and what
you're doing is deciding which pieces
are you gonna invest in creating next
and that's very important because at the
same time you must counter pieces or
units that the other player is thinking
about without having perfect information
the first step of alpha star is can you
predict where a human is gonna pick
what's the most likely mode so
essentially alpha star is gathering
information from the game where all its
units are it's getting all these data
into not a program but rather a
mathematical entity that is called
neural network that is able to then
process all this information we never
had coded what this processing means
this was fully learned from first
imitation learning trying to imitate
human moves and later on self play
through the alpha star League and after
these processing many layers of
computation of learned behavior at the
there is essentially a single action
that will be sent back to the game and
so this action could be create a new
unit create a worker send these worker
to scout move the camera to this
location and that's essentially what
alpha star is every basically 20
milliseconds in the game and every
action you see here is a result of
computation using this neural network by
January 2019 alpha star was able to beat
two professional players under special
test conditions but people wanted to see
if it could reach the Grandmaster level
beating the best players at the full
game what's quite critical is that
humans are very creative at playing this
game so once we went online with this
agent we faced all sorts of creative
strategies that we could not possibly
have ourselves designed so the very
first game that we entered we were
playing against obviously someone we
don't know so it really was like a lot
of adrenaline and a great moment to let
people essentially experience what it is
to play against such a strong AI alpha
star progressed by playing against
itself against a range of human players
and crucially by playing against other
AI agents we have this league of agents
where all the agents are doing safe play
in a manner that is perhaps a bit more
advanced than what has been done before
and there we did perhaps the most
research advances in the last few months
in which we discovered that it's not
sufficient to have only one agent that
its sole purpose is to beat itself and
it's past versions of itself it's very
important to add agents that find flaws
in the main agents right so we call
these agents exploiter agents and if you
will it's kind of asking for a friend to
beat your current strategy and maybe
this strategy that is going to beat you
is not a great strategy in isolation but
it's certainly gonna help you become a
better player and that core idea plus
them some extra developments in
imitation learning and reinforcement
learning that we had in the project
created an artificial intelligence agent
that can play the game of starcraft 2 at
a Grand Master level actually I used to
play the game back
the 90s I played quite seriously the
first version of the game one of the sad
things that happened is that I kind of
waited too long to play against alpha
star so the team was really are like
Oriole you should play at some point I
decided okay I'll play against the agent
I played when it was just strong enough
that there was no chance for me to win
and I just basically lost the window for
me to kind of defeat the agent sadly so
victory not for me
alpha star is broken into the top 200
players in Europe and Starcraft 2
playing the full version of the game
with all three alien races we are here
not trying to solve
Starcraft we're trying to utilize a
Starcraft for the purpose of advancing
AI research but be applied to any domain
that utilizes artificial intelligence in
any of its components and enhance for
instance its robustness its capabilities
to do imitation learning from experts
and other things that we deem super
important and that Starcraft really let
us test on one of the most complicated
video games ever created success in the
real world is a little more complicated
computer games can readily provide the
data points and AI needs to master a
challenge but not every problem provides
so much accurate feedback the
integration of AI into everyday life
will be a much longer battle
you
[Music]